bonjour catherine conconne bonjour
mondial tant il faut je vous vois vos
auditeurs sénatrice de la martinique on
a entendu tout à l'heure dans le journal
troisième au by side en l'espace de
quelques jours en martinique
j'imagine que cette vague de violence
que si qui s'abat sur notre pays ne vous
laisse pas différente
oui nous sommes une société violente
c'est un constat qui fait régulièrement
aussi bien par le monde de la justice
que par des sociologues on connaît
l'histoire de ce pays tout ce qui va
avec comprenait aussi les conditions le
contexte dans lequel nous vivons avec
des conditions économiques qui sont
difficiles chômage endémique est
certainement une jeunesse qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas à la confiance
on pourrait dire l'ampleur de leurs
peurs oui je pense qu'il ya une
collectivité bien la seule que nous
avons la collectivité territoriale de
martinique oui dû jouer son rôle de voix
forte
autrement dit de message à passer
d'apaisement et non pas de personnes qui
met de l'huile sur le feu en permanence
mais qu'on puisse distiller un message
qui soit celui de la paix 2006 question
oui qu'il se dit parler parler les
personnes au pouvoir aujourd'hui il faut
qu'ils aient une image de personnes
beaucoup plus apaisé qui passe des
messages à cette jeunesse qui soit plus
en phase avec elle plus en phase avec
cette société qui demande de
l'apaisement est il ce n'est pas le cas
alors vous soniques louis ce n'est pas
le cas oui en particulier de ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui en gouvernance et qui
mériterait de nous donner d'autres
spectacles que ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui
quand il s'adresse dans leur conférence
dans les réunions où l'irascible laisse
prend la place sur l'apaisement dont on
a tous besoin une autre parole forte la
parole présidentielle c'était jeudi
dernier catherine conconne à emmanuel
macron a annoncé ces orientations à lui
pour sortir de la crise des gilets
jaunes qui a débuté en octobre novembre
une sénatrice qui se dit que ça ne peut
qu'aller mieux puisque la parole
présidentielle a été dit
pas du tout moi je
je ne souhaiterais pas à mon pire ennemi
d'être à la place de ce président la
république
le mot est lancé et crise nous sommes en
pleine crise et lorsque vous êtes en
crise la demande se fait de plus en plus
fortes de plus en plus tenace et vous
aurez beau aller décrocher la lune avec
vous dont il y aura toujours des
personnes voient la majorité des
personnes qui seraient satisfaites
donc il y a un travail de communication
important à mener et je crois que c'est
ce qui a manqué à ce gouvernement qui tu
es le début de sa prise de fonction a
donné des signaux de rupture avec la
dialectique qui doit s'installer entre
un gouvernement et le peuple et cette
rupture a crié cette situation qui est
toujours d'une situation de défiance
tout ce qui va être dit va critiquer
tout ce qui va être dit va être refusée
et lorsque vous avez aujourd'hui près
d'une trentaine de samedi où l'ia entre
guillemets le feu en france partout des
affrontements des pillages des
situations peut-être mais il ya eu on a
atteint des pics de satisfaction qui ont
été très importants mais ce sera
difficile alors je dis je disais il y à
une série de six dans cette équation
qu'il s'agit pas aujourd'hui de résoudre
il y à des annonces qui sont
intéressantes
il faut écouter moi je pense aux
nombreuses femmes qui élèvent des
enfants qui ont divorcé au kiwi des
enfants et qui aujourd'hui ont du mal
par exemple on se voit on leur posera
dans l'hôtel c'est très important
qu'aujourd'hui un organisme comme la
caisse d'allocations familiales prennent
le relais eveas à la place du pq parents
défaillants parce qu'il ya aussi des
femmes qui payent des pensions
alimentaires versées à la place du
parents défaillants à des femmes qui se
retrouvent souvent difficultés
pécuniaires difficultés de pour élever
nos enfants parce qu'il ya une
défaillance et on sait très bien que la
justice peut être lente peut être
l'autre les procédures prennent du temps
en un engorgement des parquets il ya
d'autres mesures un kiss qui mérite
d'être écouté les maisons proximité
également là dedans lors de la question
des retraites puisque dans un pays
présenté comme parmi les plus les plus
vieux de france les retraites de moins
de 2000 euros est indexé dès le 1er
janvier vraie mesure mesurettes ou bien
tout simplement trompe l'oeil
c'était une demande qui avait été faite
puisque aujourd'hui on avait supprimé
les déclarations des retraites c'est une
demande qui avait été faite mais bon en
même temps il faut penser à cette
réalité qu'est la france est lorsque
vous avez un pays qui proue du 99 % de
son pib en dette c'est une situation
encore une fois je disais tout à l'heure
que l'on ne souhaite à son pire ennemi
autrement dit pour prendre une image qui
qui se rapproche de ce que nous pouvons
vivre le christ qui est mariée que le
public imaginez que vous payer 2000
euros quand vous gagnez 2000 euros nous
avait 2000 euros de dettes
chaque mois à payer c'est ça la
situation de la france aujourd'hui c'est
le pays européen qui produit le plus
d'endettement alors vous avez des taux
de chômage important et c'est moi
j'essaye d'être réaliste je suis
également en responsabilité politique
j'essaie d'être réaliste dans cette
mélasse le gros problème de ce
gouvernement c'est que dès le départ ils
ont créé cette situation de rupture qui
a engendré cette défiance de la
population et il faudra énormément
défaut énormément d'abnégation de regret
pour pouvoir revenir à une situation
normale
à pisé mais également beaucoup de
pédagogie mais manifestement la
population n'est pas prête à faire
autant de sacrifices parce que la
population ne veut pas avoir de vision à
court et moyen terme en dehors peut-être
de la question environnementale
la population a faim et le groupe
redoute surtout sept mois oui c'est
clair
donc on a des personnes qui sont dans
l'urgence et les difficile de faire
entendre à des personnes qui sont dans
l'urgence que l'on mend et des
politiques à moyen long terme c'est ce
qui a manqué au début il ya eu trop de
rupture trop de discours cassan qui ont
fait qu'aujourd'hui hebei un fossé
énorme entre le gouvernant son mii sont
ses ministres et la population cette
défiance est également dans la
population des élus parce qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils peuvent
faire sas entre le président de la
république le gouvernement et la
population se sont si les élus se sont
si les syndicats dès le début ont été
mis en position de de dos au mur on n'a
pas besoin de vous on fera sans vous
là maintenant le feu revient directement
au gouvernement
est-ce que jeudi dernier vous avez eu
l'impression d'avoir eu en regardant la
télévision un homme qui a changé comme
il l'a prétendu est ce qu'il ya eu
rupture par rapport à ce qu'il était
lors ce qui est arrivé à l'elysée il
exprimé des regrets je ne lui ferai pas
de procès d'intention pour lui dire que
pour dire que c'était c'était du cinéma
- si je ne suis pas non plus dans le
subjectif et dans dans l'expression des
progrès ont été lents été exprimées je
crois qu'il a retenu des choses de cette
leçon 63% des français ne sont pas
aujourd'hui aux oui mais après on juge
en fonction vous savez on est tous en
situation de responsabilité en politique
et il nous arrive d'avoir fit d'avoir
plus de mauvais chemin d'avoir fait des
mauvais choix et de devoir le regretter
donc moi je ne dirais pas on jette tout
à la poubelle et c'est un peu un
président qui a été élu démocratiquement
il y a deux ans il reste trois ans de
mandat mais maintenant il s'agit de sa
voix comme on finit ses trois ans là
comment la france se pose autrement dans
l'échiquier mondial
et moi aussi j'en appelle aux à cette
vision que nous devons avoir aussi de la
martinique la france ou s'il a réglé ses
problèmes et tout mignon il met
justement alors il a parlé de la
différenciation territoria le pacte
territorial avec un service public plus
de services publics au plus près des
gens des mères qui auraient davantage
par exemple de pouvoir par exemple
s'opposer à une fermeture d'hôpitaux est
ce que est ce que vous y croyez ça oui
millefeuille quoi il faut y croire et se
dire comment on met ça en oeuvre comment
nous par exemple dans ce petit
territoire comme la martinique qui pour
moi représente véritable laboratoire de
lutte contre les difficultés tout est
concentré ici 22.5 chômage petit
territoire qui en fonte démographique
moins trente mille habitants en dix ans
avec des défis énormes à relever en
matière de développement durable
d'équipement etc
qu'est ce qu'on fait au milieu de tout
ça comment on se prépare
moi je rêve qu'enfin les partis
politiques tous confondus se remettre à
travailler à l'intérieur de nos
chapelles puissent pouvoir travailler
autour de valeurs qui vont enfin
exprimer et que l'on sorte de cette
année d'autisme politique dans lequel
aujourd'hui on est enfoncée et qui
consiste à répondre au tac au tac à
celui ci à celui là
à être tous les jours vous ne faites pas
enlever moi j'agis pollué de oui on peut
le faire élever la voix offre d'auto oui
mais on peut élever la voix on peut
contester mais pas comme ça aujourd'hui
quel est le cap politique de la
gouvernance en place à la 7e
je ne sais pas mais là maintenant non
mais il ya une gouvernance en place moi
je demande plus de visibilité aux
autocars politique mais deuxième homme
et tous les partis politiques chacun
retrouve ses valeurs
comment voit-on le pays de demain comme
qu'est ce qu'on attend de nous politique
pour la martinique
nous avons un pays formidable qui a des
potentiels extraordinaire comme on fait
paul est valorisée offert de vraie
valeur ajoutée pour réduire cette
inactivité chronique dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui enfoncé et qui mérite
aujourd'hui conçois qu'on laisse la
place à l'imagination au travail
moi je m'appelle à 7 à son retour aux
valeurs et à son retour au travail et à
la réflexion politique
catherine conconne toujours dans le
chapitre de la décentralisation emmanuel
macron le président de la république a
reconnu que des choses ont été faites en
ce sens mais qu'un bon diamètre
quand même toujours cette dualité entre
plus de responsabilités aux
collectivités locales et puis cette
omniprésence de l'état qui avec qu'il
faut toujours installée de navettes pour
avoir ont fait on fait pas est ce que
vous avez l'argent est ce qu'on aura
l'argent comment on fait qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
il souhaiterait que cette
décentralisation nouvelle s'accompagne
de plus de moyens c'est une réalité ce
sont des des politiques publiques il
faut mettre à jour en permanence entre
le premier acte de décentralisation sous
françois mitterrand 90e qu'avait été
menée à l'époque par gaston defferre
qu'installer des régions etc pour
capitaliser un peu plus l'action à
l'intérieur des territoires et
aujourd'hui nous sommes à loeb de 2020
et kylie a aujourd'hui des des choses
énormes qu'il faut régler que l'on
connaissait pas en grève des chauffeurs
de complète voilà il faut des transferts
de compétences sur la joue aussi il a
souhaité qu'il y ait des transports des
transferts qu'ils se fassent plus en
bloc
autrement dit vous occuper du logement
vous occuper du logement de a à z
responsable jusqu'au bout oui moi je
nomme je n'ai en tout sens je n'ai pas
de déclic par rapport à cela que je
demande c'est que nous martinique
quels transferts de compétences nous
aurions aimé avoir quel bloc de
compétences sur lesquels nous aimerions
travailler
c'est ce travail que nous devons faire
pour ne pas être pris de co parce qu'à
force ne passe proposé à force de ne pas
être en perspective une fausse
opposition force ne pas être force de
proposition et dont on se retrouve tous
les jours le même contexte des à
contester des actions qu'on nous aura
donné au fur et à mesure parce que on y
trop de langue aux sentiments on est
trop dans le une contestation sans être
en perspective et en force de
proposition sur la paix sociale il ya eu
des transferts de compétences mais
l'argent n'est pas venu on est d'accord
par exemple rsa moi j'estime que les
naissains widgets
j'ai des paroles itau alors qu'on ait
des moyens de sortir cette c'est plus de
50000 personnes qui aujourd'hui vivent
de ces minima sociaux qu'on ait de vrais
moyens et de vraies compétences pour
pouvoir les sortir de l'inactivité
s'entendre comme comme le président le
paumé au plein emploi je n'y crois pas
aujourd'hui de manière certaine mais il
y a aujourd'hui des choses à mettre en
heure et c'est pourquoi j'en appelle à
anjou à se mettre à travailler et à erp
en perspective pour ne plus subir est
elle simplement dans le ressentiment
dans la critique permanente 80 comme
sénatrice dans son caddie si bonne
journée merci beaucoup